[Musique]
du chemin de ronde inaccessible au
public au groupement de gargouilles et
sculptures qui ornent le château de
blois l'exposition un château son cliché
offre aux visiteurs une ballade
intimiste une autre façon de regarder
cet édifice renaissance qui a été le
lieu de résidence de d'irene et de 7,3
de france on voit tout d'une autre
manière même nous on s'est aperçu qu'en
quand on avait certaines photographies
avec certains éclairages de certains
buste de sculptures d'oeuvre à huy avait
ça assez comme ça à cebu là on l'avait
pas vu du tout de cette manière là donc
déjà c'est offrir un autre regard sur le
château et pouvoir regarder des endroits
qu'on qu'elle n'a pas accès
habituellement les photographies sont
exposées un peu partout dans le château
là-haut n'y a pas de mobilier à
l'extérieur sur la terrasse délice c'est
un voyage dans le temps qui est proposé
aux visiteurs grâce à des clichés pris à
un siècle et demi d'intervalle sur la
photographie de gauche qui est datée
camp de 1862 un élément de galeries au
pied à gauche du grand escalier en vis
et cet élément a disparu dans la
photographie actuelle et cet élément a
été restauré un temps par le
restaurateur du château d'alors qui
voulait refaire cette galerie qu'on
trouve sur les desseins du 16e siècle
qui était une innovation de catherine de
médicis cette innovation sera supprimée
à la fin du 19e siècle par un
restaurateur qui voulait redonner au
château l'aspect qu'il avait sous
françois 1er toutes ses anecdotes et ses
détails insolites ont été réunies dans
un livre aux éditions du patrimoine un
livre intitulé regards comme le nouveau
regard que vous porterez sur le château
de blois après avoir parcouru cette
exposition son cliché